y aquí se inicia un anillo de seguridad
rodeado por seis escoltas y dentro de
una zona protegida es la única forma
para el ex alcalde de saravena de hacer
campaña por el candidato de derecha
federico gutiérrez y vivimos pues con
mucho mucho cuidado para evitar que nos
pase al yesid fue secuestrado y víctima
de varios atentados por eso hasta la
serie de campaña está dentro de la zona
de seguridad fico viene con una
propuesta política demócrata cierto de
fortalecer las grandes empresas que
cuando acabemos las empresas se nos
acaba la oportunidad laboral y nosotros
los colombianos no somos anglos
pero las guerrillas también ponen la
mira contra la izquierda
nelson suárez lidera la campaña de
gustavo petro en saravena en enero tuvo
que salir del departamento por las
amenazas de las disidencias de las farc
contra líderes sociales el mensaje es
claro y no se asusten les gusta de
sobremanera pues nosotros estamos
impulsando la idea de gustavo petro la
presidencia francia márquez a la
vicepresidencia pero nelson volvió a
saravena para hacer campaña por el
cambio sale con sus compañeros a
entregar revistas electorales no incluso
fuera del anillo de seguridad
nosotros necesitamos realmente que esto
cambie necesitamos que cambie la guerra
que la violencia que cese la violencia y
pasemos a una era de paz el ejército de
liberación nacional y disidentes del
acuerdo de 2016 entre el estado y las
farc arauca vive en medio del fuego
entre dos guerrillas desde enero
saravena registra al menos 75 asesinatos
en una lucha por el control del
territorio y del tráfico ilegal hacia
venezuela en medio del conflicto armado
que vivimos nosotros los jóvenes le
apostamos a la cultura y le apostamos a
salir adelante después de décadas de
conflicto en arauca hay poca expectativa
electoral y en cañas que organiza este
evento de cultura en saravena se siente
que gane quien gane van a continuar
olvidados
un montón de dicha derecha o la
izquierda para mi vida te defiendo
siempre lo mismo en este contexto ni la
vida ni las elecciones se desarrollan
con normalidad y los araucanos se
acostumbraron a no acostumbrarse
[Música]
y hago lo necesario para cambiar mirar